look at all the teams that are currently
dealing with covet 19 issues in one form
or another whether it's facility closed
whether it's virtual meetings after
practice whether it's starting
quarterback on the covet 19 reserve list
as the detroit lions are dealing with
they get him back sunday morning the
only good news for the lions are going
against a collection of vikings
defensive backs that
probably will have a hard time covering
the lions receivers even if
matthew stafford isn't fully prepared
chris jones on the covet 19 reserve list
for the kansas city chiefs and that
close to sunday he won't be available
when the panthers come to town so
it's amazing to see what's going on by
the way you may have seen in the lower
left-hand corner trent brown the raiders
tackle back
on the covet 19 reserve list he was on
it
he was off it
they had the ivy mishap in the locker
room before the game in cleveland on
sunday where he had air in his
bloodstream peter potentially fatal
condition
spent a day in the hospital while they
conducted tests
flies back to las vegas
two days later
he's on the covet 19 reserve list again
it's amazing to me to see what's going
on here and we wish him all the best but
uh
look this just tells me
at some point there's going to be a
critical mass here
that the nfl is going to have to decide
how to deal with and we hear from time
to time they should just press pause the
only problem is if you press pause
your your players all scatter
right that having a place to go every
day we heard this argument as it related
to college football and i didn't like
that argument because it was all about
making sure that the college football
billion dollar machine continues to kick
out money for everyone but the players
but the nfl level i can
i can get behind the idea
that
even if you stop playing games
you got to keep the guys in the routine
of coming to work
at a time when the virus is spreading
like never before
it's you know pressing pause to me is
impractical
it's just because to me it's just going
to exacerbate the problem
when you press pause what do you do
do you say okay no football this week
um
and and everybody is going to have only
virtual meetings do you think everybody
is going to live only virtual lives i
don't think so
that's the issue unless you are in an
nba or nhl type bubble
and the nfl isn't and won't be until at
least
january in the post season
if you know unless you have a bubble
it's fruitless to press pause on the
season
mike i want to bring up the baltimore
ravens because i think the ravens
are one are in a really unique and sort
of teetering on the edge position right
now as it relates to covet because as of
today
today's practice with the ravens
they will be without
a five starting defensive players
in their back end linebackers and
secondary five guys and that includes
marlon humphrey who's obviously out for
this game because he has tested positive
for colvin but imagine patrick queen
made so many big plays against the the
steelers last week matthew judon who's
their biggest
their most dangerous edge player desean
elliot who stepped in and done a
wonderful job for earl thomas
and then you know so you look at the
guys who they're missing
and you say to yourself okay what's
going on with them what's going to
happen with them
they cannot practice
until saturday
so just envision this they're at home
all week they're staying at home the
only thing they do is they come in and
they get their coven test they get back
in their car and they drive away and
they go home
and participate in virtual meetings you
know
maybe they're doing something as far as
to keep in shape and and physically to
you know to be okay assuming they're all
feeling well and you haven't heard of
any positive tests so you assume that
you know it's just it you know in the
proverbial abundance of caution
that they are using now because they had
close contact with marlin humphrey but
but i the only reason i bring a lot of
this up
is that
look
sunday i wouldn't call it a must win but
it's damn close for the baltimore ravens
they are at indianapolis coming off
another bad big game
by lamar jackson okay
and and and so on sunday they're playing
a team in the indianapolis colts who's
got who got their act together on
offense phillip rivers one turnover in
the last two weeks 113 quarterback
rating
he is he's
you know seemingly on right now you've
got to play very well and you've got
basically now going up against the
number two defense in football
and
so you've got to lean on this offense to
be the real big factor in this game
because you really don't have much of an
idea how is their defense going to play
when they haven't been together the
whole week the entire week mike not just
a few days they have not practiced once
as a defense the entire week and so you
have to ask yourself the question
how much is kovit going to damage the
baltimore ravens
this would have been a good week to have
a gimme game
this is not a gimme game in indianapolis
on sunday
yeah but i still have faith in john
harbaugh and company to coach up the
guys they have to make sure their guys
are ready it isn't going to be easy
and and look 265 rushing yards against
the pittsburgh steelers last week i
think the ravens have plenty of reasons
to feel good about their offense coming
out of that game i agree lamar jackson
can't play like that on a regular basis
it's going to be impossible to win
consistently if he does
but between j.k dobbins and gus edwards
and lamar jackson cranking up the
yardage they did if they can do that
again it's not going to be any easier
against the colts defense than it was
against the steelers but they still
pulled it off i've got faith in the
ravens but it is a difficult situation
and it's one of these
byproducts of one positive that you find
out about after the player has been
around the team and for marlon humphrey
it was a full game around the team
locker room before the game on the field
in pre-game warm-ups on the sideline
when the offense was playing on the
field with his teammates
and
it's
unfortunate but as we said last segment
this is what the nfl is trying to do to
hold everything together and get the
games played in a pandemic and that's
why the ravens are in this situation
let's move on to the raiders because the
raiders have gotten their punishment
multiple reports indicating that
for the trent brown positive and
everything that flowed from that
multiple players gone for several days
investigation into whether or not covet
19 protocols were followed the nfl and
the nflpa concluded they were not a 500
000 fine imposed on the raiders 150 000
imposed on coach john gruden that's on
top of the 100 000 he was fined for
blatantly failing to wear a mask on the
sidelines in week two after he failed to
properly wear one in week one and then
on top of it and this is the thing that
gets a team's attention they took away
one of the unscratched lottery tickets
from the hall of draft picks that the
raiders have in 2021 a sixth round pick
gone this is an acceleration of past
penalties imposed on the raiders if they
continue these issues the penalties will
increase the titans only got a 350 000
fine for their issues from earlier in
the season the raiders got whacked
though because they're not first-time
offenders i still think it's hilarious
when i think of john gruden saying a few
weeks ago we're on the cutting edge of
beating the virus peter i'd hate to see
where they'd be right now if they
weren't in gruden's estimation on the
cutting edge of beating it because the
league and the virus have been beating
the raiders
11 days ago john gruden said and i quote
we've done everything we can to follow
protocol
i mean that's a that's a ridiculous
statement
it just it just is
you know trent brown didn't wear his
tracking device
to a practice
how possibly can you say you've done
everything you can you know to stop the
virus it's so look
you know the raiders right now are
learning a very hard lesson
it is the same lesson in not in anywhere
near as as as big away
but the raiders are learning the lesson
that the new orleans saints learned
uh in bountygate
and that is if you are in charge of this
team
we're holding you responsible so sean
payton maybe you didn't know about what
was going on in greg williams defensive
team meetings
mickey loomis maybe you didn't know what
was going on in greg williams defensive
team meetings but you know what you're
in charge of this franchise so sean
payton you're whack for a year mickey
loomis you're whack for eight games and
so that is what's going on right now
with john gruden
he's in charge
and he has to do a better job
of follow of doing everything he can you
got to do everything you can and really
do everything you can to follow protocol
yeah and look i don't understand it
because if you want to be the best team
you can be we alluded this last segment
the steelers are not going to have these
issues and if they do they're going
gonna have to answer to an angry mike
tomlin or as the case may be angrier
than he usually is that demeanor has
been successful in getting guys to do
the things they are supposed to do he
controlled antonio brown for nearly a
decade for crying out loud we have
learned how difficult of an assignment
that can be
as he bounced around other teams last
year so
i don't understand
why
every nfl coach didn't just accept they
had five months to come to terms with
this it's real it's not fake it's not a
hoax it's not something that's going
away the day after the election this is
something that you have to keep out of
your facility and if you fail to keep it
out of your facility and if you fail to
keep anyone who has it
from spreading it to other players you
will have competitive consequences by
way of having key players not available
or not prepared to play and you will
have punitive measures imposed upon you
by the league and it's astounding to me
that a guy like john gruden who seems to
be smart enough peter
to understand this this is not some
complicated high-level math this is very
linear follow the rules
keep your guys from doing things they
shouldn't do keep your guys from going
to an indoor event with no one wearing
masks with way too many people in the
room i mean when i saw that
i i said to myself and i probably said
it out loud on this program what the
hell is john gruden doing in all of this
because if gruden is controlling the
locker room the way he should
this never
happens and it's the ultimate pass fail
either you're getting your guys to do
the things they should do and not do the
things they shouldn't do
or you're not
and look look at what's happened with
the raiders i don't know what their
record would be if they hadn't had these
issues they still may have lost to the
buccaneers
but
this is an example of what happens when
the coach
chooses
because i can't imagine he's incapable
of doing this i think this is what
happens when the coach chooses
not to say the things not to hold the
guys accountable not to do the things
necessary to ensure that there's full
compliance and in turn no consequences
for failure to comply
yeah i think after they had and and were
sanctioned lightly
for the uh the charity event in which
they were all on stage without masks on
um in las vegas
um i think after that that should have
been the moment where gruden stood in
front of his team and said listen
we there's we we're having there's zero
excuses from now on to not know the
rules and we're not gonna we're not
gonna take anymore and even though we're
playing we're paying
uh trent brown a jillion dollars this
year whatever his salary is it's huge
whatever his cap number is
um they have to be willing john gruden
has to be willing to stand up in front
of his team and says anybody violates
these protocols we're going to go after
you in a disciplinary way and we'll
limit your playing time you know that's
that he he's got to do something
uh because what he's done at least up to
this point has not worked
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports